germain et germaine sont retraitées
depuis plusieurs années germain vient de
signer la location à long terme d'une
voiture il a beaucoup de plaisir au
volant de sa nouvelle auto mais quelques
mois plus tard il meurt une fois remise
de ses émotions
germaine doit s'occuper de la succession
elle ne conduit plus depuis longtemps et
elle pense qu'il lui suffit de remettre
la voiture de son mari au
concessionnaire pour mettre fin au
contrat de location
mais ce n'est pas aussi simple bien des
gens pensent que la mort met fin à un
contrat mais c'est un mythe
il reste en vigueur et est
automatiquement transmis à la succession
pour résilier le contrat germain la
succession va devoir débourser des
milliers de dollars
le fin mot de l'histoire un contrat de
location d'autos c'est du solide
même après un décès lui est toujours
vivant